questions I gave you a question I can
give the answers to the questions what's
up welcome to the first ask IG episode
of 2010 I'm so excited because well I've
got a koala bear here with some pink
headphones I want to start this first
question off as a Twitter question from
Michael roll has somebody been calm
because he wants to know if I name my
electronics as a matter of fact I do I
named my MacBook Pros sexy the treadle
wants to know if I play any musical
instruments well I actually I used to
play guitar but I wasn't very good at
but now I'm started playing the keyboard
which I'm actually also not very good at
hey I do hi I did I'm doing really well
thanks for asking
I'm the seller you're a sailor and right
now I'm in the middle of the Pacific
Ocean actually you don't really look
like you're in the middle of a cific
ocean you actually look like you're in
some sort of empty room do you know
where Portugal do I know where Portugal
is actually I know exactly where it is
so here's a question from skylight and a
bunch of zeros and they're asking me if
Steve is a good kisser I know I just I
need to just be a little honest with you
guys I'm pretty sure that Steve Jobs
probably thinks that I'm an obsessive
stalker so I think that I need to tone
down the Steve Jobs jokes a little bit
before I actually get a restraining
order so from here on in I'm gonna
desert to wants to know what other show
I'd love to guest star in other than
booty I absolutely love the show house
so if anybody knows anyone that knows
someone that knows someone that might
know someone that works in house hi I
could make a great patient like Amy act
like I have a sickness
professional
on Facebook so just because I felt like
I didn't answer enough questions I
decided to hurry up and jump on Facebook
and ask you guys any question maybe
wants to know what my favorite thing is
on Facebook
it's a real problem what sport is IG
best at is sleeping a sport the right
will thanks so much for watching this
episode of ask IJ and stay tuned for
next episode where I answer all your
questions just answer malla just answer
it was so well